the one cohort that I'm doing really
poorly with is baby bumbers we need a
new wild card to get out of this
nonsense right and and one way we get
out of this nonsense is waking more
people up getting people to not buy the
nonsense from CNN and MSNBC and the rest
of the uh Legacy Media that would be a
go a long way because if we could wake
up more people now then we got time
before we get to that election uh here's
one more from RFK talking about the
mainstream media landscape and how we
need a shift because that will actually
cause ultimately voting habits to be
different the one cohort that I'm doing
really poorly with is Baby
Boomers and I ought to do be doing I
ought to be doing thank you thanks all
the old people like me and I I ought to
be doing really great with them because
you know they're the people who remember
Camelot and the Kennedy
era but you know they have a disability
which is they only get their news from
Ab from from ABC NBC CNN MSNBC and the
New York
Times And if I were living in that
information ecosystem I'd have a low
opinion of myself as well but what we're
finding is if they you know the young
people are are getting their information
from long form interviews from podcasts
from other alternative inter so they're
they're doing critical thinking and
they're not locked into these
orthodoxies
and somehow if you're young and you have
parents uh you need to walk them up
somewhere and make them listen to a Joe
Rogan
podcast all right so do you get it I'm
not telling you he has all the answers
you guys know I disagreed with him on
this show about the affirmative action
decision and actually by the end I kind
of got him to come around to my position
a little bit more uh he is definitely
more more into the climate stuff than I
am into or at least believing that that
humans can do something about it um
there there are probably a series of
other disagreements that we have but
does the guy love America yes does he
see the problem with the mainstream
media yes does he want accountability as
it relates to covid yes and there are a
series of other things that make sense
with this guy so I don't know where he
fits into the ecosystem and that really
wasn't the Genesis of the whole show The
Genesis of the whole show is that there
are more of us waking up and we've got
to figure out how to Wrangle some cats
right now into a movement because who
knows what happens you you might be on
the Trump train and you do not know if
all these cases removing him maybe it
just doesn't work out maybe he doesn't
get on the ballot like who the high hell
knows so we better start thinking about
things a little more holistically or
it's going to roll around to uh early
January
2025 and it could be far worse than Joe
Biden it could be it could be
Skeletor